another story on the front page well
frustration today if you've tried to go
online and use a State website because
they're all down a huge internet outage
has affected most Nevada state sites
Christian cause it is live this
afternoon at the DMV near Flamingo and
Buffalo where Christian people are angry
oh yeah John let me tell you so many
folks out here telling us that they're
frustrated and they're upset because
they said that they never really got a
notification about this outage they are
finding out as they're arriving to the
DMV specifically this location here off
of Flamingo and Buffalo and they come
across this sign here that's basically
all over the Building closed due to
Statewide outage no ETA again this
outage has all DMV offices in Nevada
closed for the day meaning no renewals
no driving tests and other services now
the online failure happened around 5 30
yesterday afternoon the announcement
came from the governor's office the most
that most State websites and services
were facing an internet outage due to a
physical failure with the fiber
connection due to a fire within Allstate
office buildings in Northern Nevada
internet and email are not available
desk phones and some agencies are
working now we are told repairs are
currently in progress many nevadans we
spoke to today said they are frustrated
like local resident hope Wells
it was just at the dealership and they
were saying I could do it online and I
thought oh it's pretty close and it's on
the way home from the dealership to here
that I would just stop in use a kiosk
have all the paperwork done title
transfer in the old car that's a concern
because in five days I won't be able to
drive I mean I won't have insurance
as you can imagine so much frustration
here from so many folks now I did speak
to a DMV official this morning and he
tells me all appointments will be
rescheduled he says the internet outage
is being repaired but no word yet on
when the problem will be fixed so we
invite you to stay with 8newsnow.com for
any updates Christian concert is 8 News
Now